-Our first guest tonight
is a very funny actor you know
from his work on "The Office
and "The Hangover" films.
He stars in the movie
"Together Together,"
which is currently playing
in theaters nationwide.
He also stars in the new serie
"Rutherford Falls,"
which is streaming
now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-A chew stick.
-Yes, Lawrence Rutherford'
chew stick.
Your ancestors taught him
how to make one.
It's very simple. You ju--
-Bristle the edges by pounding
it with a stone and chew on it
with some mint.
-Exactly. And then my family
brought that technology
to the masses,
selling toothbrushes
to soldiers and fur traders.
-Guess you could say
we got the short end
of the stick on that one.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one.
I'm going to use that.
Can I use that?
-No.
-Then I won't.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Ed Helms.
How are you, Ed?
It's lovely to see you.
-I am...pretty good.
-That is -- You know what? W
will fully take that these days.
You are someone like myself,
who has a toddler.
I've got a couple. You've go
one. How has the last year been?
-Uh...terrific?
'Cause I'm an amazing dad.
And my daughter is an angel.
She's perfect.
No, it's been trying.
Um -- [ Laughs ]
There's something about the --
this much time together
that is both amazing
and incredible and also it's -
uh, well, how can I say --
complicated.
-You know, though,
I have to say,
I feel as though I'm about t
shame other dads on your behal
because you took up some
crafting with your daughter.
-Yeah.
-And we've shown
some pretty janky crafts tha
parents have done for their kids
over this past year,
but, Ed, these are
genuinely impressive.
Tell me a little
about this train here.
-Yeah. So, that was right at
the beginning of the pandemic.
I was sort of spiraling,
and I just needed somethin
to focus on.
This was more for me
than my kid.
And it took me like three week
of full-time paper-mache
and cardboard work.
Pretty proud of that one
actually.
-This is beautiful.
A treehouse,
but the treehouse, like,
looks beautiful but maybe
did not have the best ending
-Yeah. That one --
That was really fun to make.
And then I'm really proud of it.
My daughter loves it.
And an arborist came and told us
that that tree is dying and will
probably need to be taken out.
-Arborists almost never have
good news, is my experience.
And then I'm going to
just be honest with you
so you don't think I was jus
blowing smoke on the first two
This is a pretty --
pretty bad rocket ship.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
So, yeah, about a couple month
into the pandemic,
we just started phoning it i
and just sort of
throwing things together.
-Yeah, but, no.
I mean, they're really good.
Good tug boat. The tug boa
I'm very impressed with.
-Yeah, tug boat, I was getting
my act back together again
I put some more effort,
some design work into this one
-And this is like --
This looks professional, Ed.
-That's -- Thank you.
Yes, this was next-level.
I really went after it
on a doll house.
-Did you, like, leave --
Is that sand paper,
like, there to impress us,
to let us know exactly
the amount of elbow grease
you've put into this?
-Yeah, yeah. Oh, I'm still
working on that one.
-You must be happy to hear tha
the CDC has stopped the paus
on the Johnson & Johnson vaccine
because I hear tell
that that is what you received
-Yeah. Yeah.
I got the Johnson & Johnson.
And, yeah, I was lucky.
It didn't get any side effects
or anything, and I think -
It's weird. Like, that's
the shampoo company, right
-Yeah.
-Baby shampoo.
That's my association
with Johnson & Johnson.
-No tears.
-That's all I think of.
So to think that, like,
the baby-shampoo company
is helping save the planet
is a little bit of
a cognitive disconnect.
-Yeah.
I haven't thought about that
It's also weird to think
that they eat
at the same cafeteria --
like, the shampoo people
and the vaccine people.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
They're just swapping stories,
and the shampoo people are
like, "Well,
we're -- we're saving kids
from lice, I guess."
But I couldn't help wonderin
when I got this shot
if maybe it was baby shampoo
-Oh, I see. Yeah.
See, it's fun at this poin
to hear a new conspiracy theor
that you haven't heard before.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Not to contribute
to vaccine skepticism.
I completely endorse it.
Go get vaccinated.
-That baby shampoo does a wonder
on the coronavirus.
Um, hey, one thing
that I feel a lot of peopl
return to during the pandemic,
not just because
it is wonderful,
but it also is great comfort
to people, is "The Office.
Have you -- I mean, I know
from, you know, being friendly
with so many of you in that cast
that over the years you continue
to hear more and more
about the show.
But this year must've been eve
exponential compared to that
-Yeah.
I mean, the staying power of
that show is totally incredible.
It's breathtaking.
And I heard from so many friends
and loved ones
that they were tuning in to kind
of get through the tough times
And it's just a testament
to the -- I think,
how warm that show is.
You know? Like, it's reall
about a community.
It's about people
that are there for each other.
And that's what we need
sometimes.
-You met Mike Schur
working on that show,
and he has since made
so many shows
that are about communities
and about warmth and character
And you had long wanted
to do a show,
the two of you guys together
and now you have
with "Rutherford Falls."
How did it come about?
-Yeah, so, we were buddies
on "The Office."
He's -- You've known him
from "SNL" days, right?
He has terrible things
to say about you.
-He's a bad guy. He's a bad guy.
-He's a terrible person.
[ Laughter ]
But we just, yeah, always wanted
to do something together,
and then we had this idea
about, like,
what if somebody's really having
trouble coming to terms
with historical narratives
and whether or not they're true,
and why do we cling
to these things,
and what happens
when they're proven false?
And we roped in our friend
Sierra Teller Ornelas
because the show had a stron
Native American component,
and we realized we're not
equipped to tell those stories
And Sierra's Navajo, and w
wound up with a writer's roo
that's half Native American,
and it's become
this really meaningful momen
of Native American
representation
that I'm insanely proud
and humbled to be a part of.
And it's also a comp--
totally hilarious show.
-[ Laughs ] It's very funny.
I was deeply offended
by the Northwestern University
burn in the pilot.
Just want you to know that
-Uh, it comes back around.
Keep watching 'cause
Northwestern gets some love.
-Okay. Thank you very much
-All right? Okay.
-Hey, you're also --
You have a new film in theaters,
"Together Together."
Is it fun being out with two
different things that --
I'm assuming you're proud of
"Together Together," as well
-I love that movie.
"Together Together."
I'm insanely proud of it.
Patti Harrison is my co-star
She's just a brilliant
hilarious human being.
And, yeah, it's a little
overwhelming having two things
coming out
right at the same time,
but there's something
really nice about a movie
coming out in theaters, right?
-Yeah.
-It's like --
-I think --
I mean, I think the fact tha
you have two things coming out
at the same time,
we can forgive, like,
how the rocket turned out.
You know what I mean?
-Here's the crazy thing, Seth.
That rocket? It works.
-Oh, okay.
-It's been to space.
That rocket --
-Well, now I take it all back.
Hey, congratulations, buddy.
It is always really nice
to see your face.
-It's great to see you, Seth
Cheers. Thanks.